so we learned in the last lesson how we
could run the mutability analysis and
interpret the results
from the pca plots that we obtained from
mutability analysis
we can clearly see that the samples from
2015
form distinct clusters in comparison to
the samples from 2009
based on the mutability data
thus it would be interesting to know
which chromosomes or genes have variants
between both groups of samples
one of the ways to address this question
is by differential mutation analysis
so let's learn how we can perform
differential mutation analysis based on
ngs data from these two different years
using the t-bioinfo server
so to begin with the pipeline we need to
choose mutation variant analysis under
the genomics section on the t-bioinfo
server
the parameters to be set will be as type
of reference genome should be arjun or
gtf since here we are not using model
organism so we need to provide reference
genome for desired organism that is
plasmodium falciparum the format of ngs
data should be fastq
and it should be peer end for
this example as we have taken the pair
and read data
next to upload the ngs data
we can do so by using multiple options
files can be uploaded as ftp or svl
links it could be uploaded as ncpi run
table as well files can also be uploaded
as dot txt file containing svl or ftp
links for all the samples
next we need to upload the reference
genome of selected organism here we are
using plasmodium falciparum so click on
add more option to create get link
option subsequently paste the links for
faster file of reference genome and jdf
gff file for reference genome
next to select the groups drag the
samples into respective groups here we
are considering 2009 samples as control
groups and 2015 samples as treatment
groups
now we are all set to start the pipeline
so just click on the start button you
will get a pop-up click on the ok to
start the pipeline
to align the raw sequence reads of ngs
data here we are using the bauti
algorithm
by clicking on the bounty option you
will get a pop-up and click on save to
proceed further
next we need to perform per nuclear
mutation analysis
per nuclear is an algorithm that
calculates the per position coverage of
the reference genome by all variants
the output of this module is a table
with all the positions of the genome and
the calculated coverages of each
position by each variant
next we need to perform
binom 95
mutation called binom 95 is a module
that performs calculation of the 95
percent confidence interval for
frequency of every variant at the genome
position based on will's theorem for
binomial distribution
after running mutation called binom 95
now we need to run the differential
mutation
differential mutation analysis signifies
differentiation between frequencies of
samples for passage 1 and frequencies
for samples for passage 2 of the same
mutation in two contrasting samples or
passages
frequency of the mutation of sample 1 of
passage 1 is f1
here it is mentioned as a blue bar on
the left and frequency of the same
mutation of sample 1 of passage 2 is f2
it can be seen as green bars on the
right
now to learn more about some of the
important terminologies associated with
differential mutation such as regression
what is cautionization
standard deviation you can refer to the
lesson on omics logic learn portal under
genomics section
the lesson on differential mutation
it's time to end the pipeline give a
name to your pipeline
and run on cluster
this pipeline can take more than 72
hours to complete or more than that
depending on the number of samples
uploaded please keep patience when
looking at the results
once the pipeline is completed you can
find all the outputs under the download
output file folder
mapping stats table contains the mapping
statistics of the pipeline
def custom file results filtered score
contains a significant mutation based on
the threshold of z score that we
provided during the building of the
pipeline
this is an important output
diffcustomfinalresults.txt
contains mutations at all the positions
open tiffcustom final result filtered
score
3.txt file and some of the important
columns are
chromosome nucleotide position
reference allele alternate first
nucleotide alternate second nucleotide
and alternate third nucleotide
the last five columns
z score for each alternative nucleotide
or mutation
let's go for first alternated nucleotide
second alternative nucleotide third
alternative nucleotide for addition
mutation and for deletion mutation
next to compute which alternative
nucleotide mutation is more significant
and preferred at a particular position
we need to compute minimum and maximum
values for z score for five alternatives
as shown here
for instance at first position
that is nc00438.3
where thymine is replaced with guanine
would be preferred mutation because
maximum value of z score is 14.5
next we can analyze which chromosomes
have higher numbers of mutations between
both groups of samples we can also
compare mutation per chromosome between
both the groups
chromosome 4 has highest number of
mutations which include more than 7 500
between samples of 2009 and 2015.
it could be represented as a bar graph
next we can also analyze the
distribution of mutation per position
based on the mutation frequency as well
as based on z score
to learn more about how the various
types of analysis and interpretation
could be carried out refer to lesson
number 11 on differential mutation
analysis on omics logic loan portal
you can reach out to us at marketing at
atomicslogic.com
and we'll be glad to assist you with
your questions